hi everyone uh
thanks for coming to this talk uh my
name is Shashi I'm a PhD student I'm
going I'm in my fifth year now at uh at
the Julia Lab at MIT my lab
originally created the Julia language
and I work on Julia I mean I work on
this symbolic programming language
inside Julia
um
so I I started working on Julia in 2014
as a
g-soc student I've been working with
Julia since
um so like I I worked as a software
engineer for four years with Julie
Computing and uh the Julia lab now I'm
the I'm a PhD student
my advisor is Alan needleman and my
these are my collaborators whose work I
will be demonstrating today as well
um
yeah
um so
the stock is about
this thing I call symbolic numeric
programming so what does it actually
mean so inside so in simple terms it is
basically taking numerical code and
running it with symbols and
and we I wanted to explore what you can
do with this approach
and concretely this talk is about this
package called symbolics.jl it's a Julia
package and the slogan is a it's a fast
modern cast for a fast modern language
Cass means a computer algebra system
um
so
yeah so
Julia is a numerical Computing language
and numerical Computing involves
running math on computers so
if you were a programmer in the 1950s
you would first do the math on a piece
of paper and write
code in maybe four grand and then have
it compiled to machine code
and back then subroutines were like a
new invention
so like you would write this subroutine
and then it would fit into some kind of
differential equation solver and then
you would feel very good about it right
and this is uh this is still how many
people write numerical code today
um and uh
so writing code to do your differential
equations
solving is still very simple
um but we also have
if you did this maybe after 1970s you
would have some modeling language like
maybe you were using lisp or these days
you can use a simulink or mortalica or
something like that to model your
equations and that system will compile
it down to something that runs on the
machine this could be something like a c
c program or something like that which
is completely outside the language
because these languages are very high
level so now if you compile it down to C
you're giving up the advantage of being
able to use your own ecosystem
but if you're compiling to Julia
uh you can always use Julia functions
inside Julia functions so like there is
this nice closure you get
so I also said that people still write
code like this because it's actually
easy to write code like this rather than
model equations directly so you can
write for Loops for example inside this
function and have it create a bunch of
equations right
um so it is actually beneficial to take
code and run it with symbols and get
back the equations and then manipulate
the equations and then you can do things
like you can turn it back into code and
in this case
this was a function which is allocating
an array with three elements right so
this is a array expression in Julia and
it has three elements
but just by converting into math and
then converting it back into code we can
ask the
second step to make it in place so in
this case it's actually taking an input
array and then writing three elements to
it so here it's not actually allocating
a new array so if a differential
equation solver can give it a fixed
amount of memory and then do it for us
use the same memory for every step then
you've avoided about 10 000 allocations
here right because for every second of
in simulating a certain system we are
probably going to say run this function
about 10 000 times or something like
that
um
so yeah I want to switch gears and talk
about uh how symbolics works symbolics
the symbolic programming language
symbolic programming package
it's very simple on the surface you have
this macro called at variables you give
it like a bunch of variable names and it
creates those variables and then any
arithmetic you do on that will return
symbolic Expressions so here I'm doing X
Plus X Plus Y and it's already
simplifying it to 2x plus y it's
assuming that uh you know you can do it
sometimes it might also give you y plus
2X that's because
it it sorts things in hash order
uh so it's actually assuming that plus
is also commutative and here it's making
it even uh
I guess even more Blasphemous assumption
that X is never zero and it's returning
to but
um so by default the implicit types of X
and Y is real
and for real types we just do this there
is another type which you can use for
safety it's called literal real if you
use this then it does not simplify so
just like basically this package is
constructing these Expressions as you do
arithmetic on it
um and then there's this nice function
called build function to which you give
a symbolic expression and then the
inputs you want
and it returns a Julia function which
runs the symbolic expression with the
inputs
um
yeah
and in symbolics you can also have array
variables I will get I will have a more
detailed exposition of array variables
later but this here is a matrix of size
5x5 and this is a vector of length five
and if you do operations on these things
it returns symbolic expressions so a
backslash X is uh backslash is a way of
saying solve it's the same in Matlab if
you know this
um so it's saying uh solve
a for x and then this should be a vector
of length Phi because of the sizes of
the inputs there and then you can write
a star a star x and by default it
parenthesizes a star X but you can also
do it the other way
um
Which is less efficient but yeah
and when you call build function on
array Expressions it tries to do it as
fast as possible so he in this case it's
calling linear algebra.mul which is
actually a blast call blast uh for those
of you don't know is like uh it was
actually first written in the 50s and we
still still use it it's like a basic
linear algebra subroutines like
multiplication is implemented there and
there are many blast implementations
it's kind of a standard and
um it tries to use all sorts of
optimization techniques to do the things
that need to be fast very fast so here
it's a matrix Vector multiply so when we
do compile a build function call build
function on something that can be run in
plus it tries to do that
um
so coming back to the Lorenz example I
was showing you can take this function
that uh it's it's not in place it's out
of place in that it's allocating a new
array you run it with a vector variable
and this T is actually never used but
usually that's convention ah to pass in
that time so it returns a vector of
expressions
in this case
and then you can call build function on
the vector of expressions and you can
say in place equals true and it will
give you an in place output so by just
doing this simple step of going from
code to math and going from math to code
you actually optimize that piece of code
we also have other things like you can
create static vectors instead of in
place vectors static vectors are like
stack allocated because you know the
size here is just three and yeah those
things are also fast and behave like
abstract vectors in Julia so
and uh yeah so this gets turned into
machine code by Julia and
Julia is uh for those of you don't know
um Julia is a just-in-time compiled
language so sort of curiosity how many
of you use Julia
in somewhere from okay cool nice
Okay so
yeah so it's generating machine code as
you call the function
so I wanted to
try to see what we are doing in the
context of other things in computer
science that we know of so first one is
macros these are syntactic macros I'm
talking about
where you get macro stake as input some
expression and give out Expressions
right and these expressions are in the
host programming language so the
difference here is that uh
macros
cannot go into the caller into the
functions that are called in an
expression they can only work on the top
level expression but in our case we can
send a kind of these symbols into the
functions that are being called and
still get back like a simplified
expression
um
and then there is abstract
interpretation which is basically taking
a piece of code and interpreting it with
a
modified interpreter where you're saying
okay instead of doing a plus b uh
maybe say uh
find the set of possible outputs of a
plus b and stuff like that
um
I I think symbolic interpretation is
also similar to this in fact in
symbolics you can attach metadata and
kind of create a abstract interpreter
in itself but it's also like
kind of awkward to write abstract
interpreters
and then it's also similar to partial
evaluation which is
basically you take a piece of code and
evaluate it for the values you already
know and then retain the rest of the
code as it is but if you run a function
with symbols that's actually what
happens
in some sense the only difference is uh
in all these cases they they think about
scope uh where like if if two Ex two if
a function is calling another function
uh the variables there have a different
name uh here because we are passing
variables through the functions
um
it
it kind of takes care of itself
the scope okay so the elephant in the
room here is like lisp so every computer
science idea has been tried out in lisp
I'm only like 20 joking so
um
yeah so a lot of the inspiration for
this package comes from scheme
SCM utils to be exact STM retails is the
joy Professor Jerry sussman's uh
um
um I guess it's a it's a tool for doing
math he uses it for symbolic computing
um and simulating
multi-body physics basically
um
yeah so with with lisp again most of the
systems I've seen they use lisp symbols
you cannot have the symbolic types
attached to them very easily without
writing another system which overlays on
top of this which is also in his book
but uh yeah I think
um I think uh Sim what symbolics is is
doing is kind of more
um user friendly and transparent
so in the in this section I want to talk
about all the optimizations this system
makes possible uh basically the system
of taking numerical code and running it
with symbols and turning it back into
code
so the first optimization we do is uh
here's a function which uh
it's not important what the contents are
but it's taking a three-dimensional
input
and it it is creating a out uh it is
creating a
one-dimensional output
and
if you take the Jacobian of this of this
function uh so Jacobian is a derivative
of R N to RM function uh it looks
something like this here the yellow
spots are zeros and the
red spots are non-zeros so this function
is a 72 to 72 function so if you
computed every single derivative in this
Jacobian it would take like 5000
different symbolic computations which is
very slow but there are only hundreds of
non-zero elements in this so so what we
can do with symbolics is uh run this
code with on symbols and then we have a
way to find sparse jacobians which is
just saying does this expression contain
this input does this expression contain
this simple so you get back this
sparsity beforehand and then you can
just go to the non-zero places and then
do the derivatives and if you're also
doing ad which is automatic
differentiation
um so in ad you would have to perturb
every input separately so like this
function would have to be called 72
times but if you had this scarcity
pattern then you will know that like
to these two different things can be
perturbed at the same time without the
perturbations interfering with each
other so then you can do less than 72
calls to the function to find the
derivative
this is one optimization that is
possible
um so in this case we are actually
finding the Jacobian function which
again we compile down to Julia and then
give it to the solver if it needs it
and the second case is uh Spar sessions
so this is uh kind of cool like we can
write these rules which turn Expressions
into their equivalent polynomial with
the same Hessian so in this case degree
to rad is a linear function so it's just
for turning degrees to radians so it
Returns the polynomial X1 and log X1 is
a non-linear function it has the same
Hessian as x squared so we just store x
squared there and then
um
yeah in this case X1 by X4 it's
non-linear in X4 but linear index one
and the expression which has the
equivalent HD n is x 1 x 4. so basically
we can take any expression and turn it
into a polynomial and then find the
session of the efficient sparsity of the
polynomial and then go to the go to find
the Hessians which will be much faster
uh
let's see okay so here's an example of a
piece of code which we we uh
sped up using all these techniques so
here this function takes as input a 3D
3D array U and then
it allocates three slices of it first I
mean it extracts three slices of it and
then it does
it does these operations and then it
creates three different output arrays
and then again concatenates them in in
the third dimension so it takes a 3D
array and outputs a 3D array
and this at dot is a macro which is
saying do all of these element wise
right so
um so it's actually doing
three and uh three allocations here and
three allocations here right and then
again this is a big allocation here at
the end where you're concatenating and
there are allocations here too uh
but
if we um
if we run it with symbols
here do is the result of running it with
symbols and call build function on it
and build function also has this feature
of uh being able to turn code into
multi-thread code by just passing in
this thing
uh which I will get later but
so if if you ran this solve with the
sped up version of it using symbolics
you get a 150 time speed up and about
like 30 times is
just from removing those allocations
um yeah
and then
another cool optimization that's
possible is in the same system actually
um
if you call this function called
semi-linear form
what it does is
it it takes a list of Expressions d u
and then it will turn it into this form
so where a is a matrix a times U plus y
gives back to you
and
a and Y are outputs of semi linear form
so Y is a list of non-linear terms and a
is a matrix which when multiplied with u
will give you all the linear terms in
the expression and it turns out the
sparsity of a is something like this
it only has 9088 stored items if this
was very dense then this would be even
more powerful right because a star U
here would call the blast expression and
then instead of computing all those
expressions separately you would just
call Plus in this case it's doing a
matrix Vector multiply with a sparse
sparse Matrix which is also pretty fast
and the big Advantage here is if you run
this in Julia this compiles very fast as
compared to compiling a list of 3000
expressions
um I just wanted to talk a little bit
about compiling this to Julia
so compiling to Julia and how come how
is Julia itself compiles to machine code
um so Julia
is a just-in-time compiled language so
when you call a function with a set of
values it takes the types of that the
inputs and then propagates those types
into the function and all the called
functions and then compiles each one as
it figures out what the type is of each
each value that it's getting and once it
is compiled the second time you run it
with the same set of types it uses the
compiled code
um so the first time you run it
everything is very slow
and the second time it's super fast
but there is a restriction to make this
happen safely and that rest restriction
is that if you evaluate a piece of code
you cannot run that same piece of code
in the same function
like if you if you evaluate a piece of
code which returns a function you cannot
run that in the same function and this
is because
this could have invalidated some method
that's already defined and we maintain
something called the world age so when
we call this function this world Edge is
too old
are too new for to be running in the
same world so you kind of have to exit
this Loop of interpretation and come
back and run this bar to be able to run
it in a valid way so there's a kind of a
workaround for this in Julia it's called
runtime generated functions this is the
package it's written by Chris Foster
what it does is uh it takes
so when you construct a rgf it takes an
expression and it hashes it it stores it
in a hash table and then it returns a
type which is parameterized by the hash
so when this type is callable and when
you call this callable type it looks of
the expression that is stored and it
gives it to the compiler it's a
roundabout way of saying okay I know you
don't want me to do it but please do it
um
so this is what to use when we use it in
symbolics
yeah so
in Julia compilation is
um
it's it's a quadratic in the length of
the code that you write
um it's just because there's a lot of
bookkeeping to do within the same
function so one thing we can do is
um if if your function turns out to be
pretty long we can split it up into a
hierarchy of function calls that's what
symbolics does if your function is
pretty big and it also turns out that if
you just put at spawn in front of each
of these function calls it becomes
multi-threaded so this is what the
multi-threading multi-threaded form does
and in Julia there's like a work
stealing multi-threading scheduler so
like you just
do a bunch of spawns and it takes care
of load balancing so that's pretty cool
um
I think that's all about compilation
that I'm going to talk about today
um but if you have questions you can ask
me
so
um a really cool feature of symbolics is
symbolic Aris
um symbolic arrays are not
very common in symbolic algebra systems
most algebra systems just work on
scalars
variables which are real or floating
Point seeming
and what do I mean by symbolic arrays I
uh so yeah here's the table with all the
things that support symbolic rays
Maple does not
I I think uh simulink also kind of does
not uh simplify Sim engine does not
Mathematica does with the assumptions
thing
um Maxima does it and symbolics does it
um yeah by symbolic Expressions I mean
symbolic array Expressions I mean
Expressions which are which do not
depend on the size of the input so in
this case this variable is 1 to m one to
n it does not matter what M and N are
it's going to take up a constant amount
of space
and this expression it does not matter
what the size of w and X are it's gonna
just take up as constant amount of space
um
yeah we already saw this just to go over
it again if you use add variables with
the sizes you get back
array variables and you can do
operations on them
and it just keeps returning the
equivalent expression right and these
things in the square brackets here they
are showing the size of the output
um
and there's like if you look under the
hood if you set this flag it tells you
what it's actually storing under the
hood like for every operation that you
do so if you do X star y here it
actually stores this expression and
this is something known as the Einstein
summation notation
what it means is a
to compute this output
this output has one dimension and for
every element in that dimension
I
compute this and wherever there is a
missing die a dimension on the right
hand side like K is not mentioned in the
left left hand side that means reduce
over k
using the plus operation so here it's
the
this is a matrix Vector multiply and
this if you wrote a for Loop for this it
would reduce over the k
and the output will be filling up using
the eye over there
um
and
it also kind of nests into itself so in
this case we are doing three three
Expressions here three broadcast
expressions and actually this transpose
is another one so the innermost
expression
[Music]
um
ah
I think there's a typo there it should
be j i but
oh yeah actually no there's no typo so
this is a vector transpose so it's
making the First Dimension One and the
second dimension n and then this is the
broadcast of multiplying x with y
and this outer one is just doing X on
everything this calling exponent every
element
um
so
and then we have this rule system I'm
just showing it now but uh rule system
works on non-ra variables as well
so he you can you can say
match this pattern and rewrite it as
this
in this case adjoint of an adjoint is
the thing itself that's what it says and
then
the second one is more complicated here
you're saying uh if there there are two
multiplications and it turns out that
the size for the intermediate variable
for this Association is lesser than that
for this one
then do this instead so
um it's saying if a times B is bigger
than b times C just compute B times C
first so that you don't have to allocate
a bigger bigger chunk of memory so if
you this will optimize things like
Matrix Matrix Matrix times Matrix times
vector
um it will make it Matrix times Vector
times
and then Matrix times Vector
um and then the second one is a
broadcast Fusion so if you have x dot
plus y dot plus Z it'll do
um it'll do one for Loop instead of two
for loops
so this rewrite system is uh is from
this book by Jerry Sussman and Chris
Hanson
um
uh it's very cool I think uh it's worth
every I think everyone here will enjoy
um
yeah
um
yeah
so yeah here's an example of applying a
rule so here I've written a rule which
says uh
it's the Matrix chain multiplication
rule so just minimize the size and
my input is X x times y times B and I
wanted to make it y times B times x
um and sure enough the if you apply the
rule it's it's giving me y times B first
and then doing star on the
on X after that with the vector
and yeah so build function also works on
this array of you can actually directly
write array Ops this is the first time
I'm showing that but if you write this
it'll make a for Loop for you
um
using the Einstein notation
and then there is this macro called at
turbo which is like a
it's it's a very simple macro to use but
very complicated to implement uh so
there is this package called Loop
vectorization it takes uh any Loop it
you give it and then tries to make use
simdi on it same day is like uh it's
it's what it's instruction level
parallelism
um so if you have
if you have uh any modern processor it
can do multiple multiplications and
additions at the same time rather than
doing one at a time but you are
expressing for Loops where you're saying
do this one at a time but at turbo make
sure it's doing it all at once it's
using all of those registers and
and turbo is also like
it also tries to reorder the loops so
that it's it's a very cache friendly and
I think going forward they're also
trying to implement blocking which will
be which will make it basically as fast
as blast in the end
um this language also has
stencils
stencils are
basically when you have an array and
then
at every step you're looking at some
neighbors of the of that of that element
and then doing something to the
neighbors in this case this is like a
1D stencil on a on a 2d array so it's
basically
um
it's it's a it's adding two elements in
the same row
I think the second line is repeated but
I should probably have removed it but
yeah and then it has some boundary
conditions at the for the edges
um I try to cough with like very
complicated languages for writing
stencils but in the end this was like so
simple and it it uh seemed pretty
obvious like where you say I'm creating
a new array why but these components
come from this expression that's all and
it turns out to work very well
the only thing it cannot do currently is
periodic boundary conditions where
you're like at the which means that when
you're at the end of The Matrix you want
to wrap around and come here
um for that you need to be able to
self-reference
which I'm working on right yeah
um
and here's another example you can
have any expression as
as one of the components of your stencil
not not only array of expressions and
when you do chords and on this it'll
figure out the best way to run it and in
this case it figured out that the second
expression is just a multiply and then
it figures out the Right View and then
calls multiply on The View for the r to
get the output
yeah I think
recently there is a lot of interest in
array languages where like the encode
sizes in the type system Dex is one of
them and
um I don't know maybe there are other
examples that I'm forgetting
um
and I think doing it in the type system
is is great but I think it's also kind
of awkward you're trying to
um
write all of this at the compiler level
but you can actually do it
um
at the very Dynamic level at the Julia
level for example
um
yeah and then
yeah so there is a
there are a lot of details about like
how the system works like in the
beginning you saw that x plus X Plus Y
is written as 2x plus y so it actually
just creates a dictionary wrapped around
in a type
um where it's storing that X is repeated
twice and Y is repeated once and so on
um but we only have one system which
does the rewrite rules and there is an
interface which Bridges the gap between
the expression representation and how
the read write system works that is
described in this paper and we also in
this paper there's an example of using
e-graphs
egraphs is this new thing it was
it's actually pretty old but it was only
used in
theorem Proverbs before and what egrops
are is like if you give it a set of
rules which are bi-directional it can
figure out
it can basically search all possible
Expressions without
without creating exponential blow up of
memory
it's there is an example of that in in
this paper and we have been using it uh
optimize floating Point Expressions so
if you if you're given an expression how
can you rearrange this expression such
that you're not losing accuracy but also
you're minimizing the amount of CPU
Cycles it takes
um
and we are also still working on a new
system to do that as well
um
yeah and these are my collaborators
yingbo
um Alessandro roti
egraf system Chris rakakus
wrote the modeling package that uses
this and that is used by about 70 other
packages the modeling language is called
is called
modelingtoolkit.jl if you have a
modeling problem you can try look at it
because it can it can work with a large
number of different types of OD problems
or differential equation problems
um
yeah that's that's uh all I have for
today and yeah if you if you have any
questions I'd be happy to answer
[Applause]